we're living in a time where we need
healing healing messages healing music
and through playing sely I've been
healed I am
cely Suge is a woman that you're not
going to keep down and she has to do
work real work to heal she set herself
free so that she could come back and set
so many women free from this film so
many people are going to be seen they're
going to feel that renewal it's time for
you to see the
world when I was first hired to direct
The Color Purple I knew that we were
bringing an imaginative quality that
only our version has I think the very
first thing that I pitched was was this
giant gramophone scene which for me was
the moment when I understood how we were
going to oscillate between reality and
fantasy well don't just stare at it
turn when you first hear taj's voice
it's a moment of Innocence it was really
powerful because she plays it in almost
a tiptoe and there's a connection in
that moment where you going Fantasia
burino who was a bit hard to sell on
being cely with prizing her role from
Broadway I've spent some time with cely
before she's familiar to me I remember
when Blitz first called me and ask me
about planning and I ran from it for a
while he started showing me that he was
going to give sely and Imagination and
that is what drew me in when we were on
set that was like a big real life record
that they brought in and sely gets to
dance around and
sing God about a million
tingles sneaking on up my
spine I wash your body and it feel like
I'm praying try not to look but my eyes
ain't obeying that was C's moment to
allow the song to get out some things
that she really really wanted to say
that she couldn't say to sh sely and I
are so much alike especially as a kid I
would always imagine myself
somewhere so I thought it was perfect
that he just didn't keep her silent and
make people have to wonder like well I
wonder what she's thinking you get to
see what she's thinking this scene for
me was the moment when I understood how
we were going to travel through
imagination in this film and that's
where Paul asb's brilliant mind came
into work the trick was really finding
the best most appropriate gramophone so
Props got quite a number of them in and
we looked at them and then scaling it up
we built everything but the big horn we
had a giant record player with all the
grooves in it and a huge label we didn't
really move around too much the the
turntable did a
lot here comes Suge teaching her loving
on her seeing her how come you don't
laugh no that is when sely begins to
heal because somebody could see
her sweet and loving
God now it's
[Music]
talking making push the button was a
moment in my career that I will never
forget the way we framed the Juke Joint
scene was imagine the biggest artist in
the world going back home to perform in
a little hole in the wall coming in on
that bar in the swamp was so beautiful
you know that's who Suge is out in the
world this beautiful glamorous Superstar
so it was beautiful to see her
transition into that in the small town
and that was rare for women back in the
[Music]
day need
to I mean it's one thing to run it in
the rehearsal but to get it on its feet
all the lights and the costumes and the
Wardrobe that moment is all about that
Red Dress we knew is Iconic but we knew
that we needed to dial it up Francine
worked on the original 1985 Steven
Spielberg film as an assistant costumer
so my work with her was a full circle
she showed up with so much passion and
knowledge I wanted
taji not to have the sackin of the 1920s
the early 20s but to have it a little
bit more contoured of the mid and late
20s and that headdress with the pearls I
was looking at it on on the Monitor and
I thought oh my gosh it it's just all
worked everything keeping a bit within
the period pushing the period a little
so that we can remain true to it but at
the same time giving to Raji the sexy
movement that she
needed
the give me something to let the baby
know it's about a 3 and 1/2 minute song
our challenge immediately was we might
get redundant we need to figure out a
way to break it up what if the lights go
out now this gives us an opportunity to
reset and to turn the environment into a
new
[Applause]
world woo it ain't over yet
y'all the button the beautiful ending
for me is when Mister is is assuming
that she's going to come to him to watch
her navigate that and choose cely in
that moment cely was feeling like that
was the first moment somebody recognized
her in front of a community in a town
where nobody could see her everybody was
in the Juke Joint they came to see sh
Avery that was big for
her I'm full as a tick on a big old
dog let's see hey
well Sophia I think we
uh we all glad you finally home yeah
welcome home Sophie the dinner scene is
so complex because it's so important to
get everyone's point of view you sure
you want nothing eat that dinner scene
really is the Pinnacle it is family and
all of its mess and all of its
inconsistency IES coming to a head and
having to address issues that are deep
longstanding and buried under the
surface it's a very tricky scene to
shoot and kudos to Dan Lawson and to
Blitz our director it's a table of eight
characters all of who need a specific
kind of Framing and all of who need a
specific kind of light so when you're
coming into the room it's pretty dark
but it's still very very bright outside
there was like this feeling about the
bright light that couldn't come into
this like creepy house and the way we
shot it was we really have the feeling
about the light is blowing into the room
it's about time to load the luggage come
on Miss why don't you go and have some
peas and be Cil now
Papo your daddy made my life hell on
Earth he ain't nothing but a sack of
dead H and hor belong in the
ground
she call him a second of dead oh
Daniel Brooks coming alive she goes from
an entire laugh to this incredible
Traverse of
tears I have never seen anything that
special I pass
me
I want to thank you Miss
s for everything you've done for
me I was feeling by the bed rotting in
that prison cell but you came and see by
me every week
without
feel that's how I know God it's one of
the most
proudest performances I have I'm really
proud of it at the end of the day you
can rise you can get back up and I felt
that so many times in my career I just
feel like at the end of you know Alice
Walker's book she says
amen that's how I felt about that scene
and it means it is well oh Sophia home
now there's going to be some changes
made the most special element that we've
been able to contribute to the color
purple is we could find within the
character's mind actively working their
way towards healing and the only way to
heal is to forgive those who traumatized
you that's the only way you can heal you
cannot heal if you hold on to to
resentment if you hold on to anger I
think that's the beautiful thing about
humanity and people is sometimes we
don't know how to get to that place but
if you just keep putting one foot in
front of the other you will find I think
you're empowered
[Music]
sely
sely that is something that we need more
in the world today for somebody to just
they just want to be seen they just want
to be heard loved and that's when the
healing takes
[Music]
place